hello welcome to my talk I'm Laurent I
work at solando so our team is working
on payment processing and risk
management for online payments we're
detecting fraud in payments and such a
very interesting we have a lot of
interesting projects but today I won't
talk about things I do at work but I
will talk about something that I really
like to do in my free time and this
playing cards so the name of the game is
bridge and just for curiosity for a
quick survey can you please raise your
hand if you know about this game okay
there this is more than I expected quite
a few hands went up so yeah bridge is a
card game it's very interesting card
game and first of all is a nice game to
play with friends like a social game
with friends or family this is how I
usually play it in maybe in a rainy
afternoon on weekends and and such but
the game is very complex so very
interesting so people also try to play
it very competitively so it is seen also
as a kind of intellectual sport similar
like chess and goal and other
intellectual games so people would
prepare a lot for such competitions and
train a lot and practice and some people
even do it professionally and whenever
some activity is very challenging and
requires a lot of intelligence then the
computers will come and we'll try to do
it as well and they will try to do it
better than us so we have seen the news
recently how alphago is now much better
than humans when go was considered too
hard for computers and
in chess for many years already this top
fish engine is unbeatable and now it
alpha go zero is even better and there
was a lot of very good results in poker
as well on heads-up poker where humans
are also not as good as computers and
other games like backgammon checkers
everything so computers a bit as in
everything but in bridge is still a bit
different so there are good computer
computer programs super me bridge and
they play a quite solid probably better
than me but still not better than those
guys
so in bridge the computers are still not
at the human level so today we'll look
into what approaches computer bridge
programs have and how we can improve on
them of course with neural networks so
just to set the context so my main
motivation is actually to practice some
techniques and many different ways and
architectures of neural networks so my
goal is not to a bit bridge by myself in
my free time so the outline of the talks
we start with very short introduction of
the game just one slide so just enough
so you can follow along then we look at
the most common approaches of how
computers play bridge and we look at how
we use neural networks as evaluation
function to to predict outcomes in which
positions and then we look at some
totals of some conclusions so here is a
diagram with four players so four
players are outlined here so each has 13
cards so the cards are shown there and
then the way a bridge is played is like
everybody puts a card in turn and and
when all four players have put a card on
the table then this is called a trick
and somebody wins this trick and then
next trick and next week so there are
thirteen tricks in total so you can win
maximum of thirteen tricks and minimum
of zero so here down there in the corner
is shown that team NS has won three
tricks and three e W has won one trick
so what we'll try to do in this talk is
to built a neural network that can
predict how many tricks will be won by a
team and s so there there are already
algorithms who can solve this perfectly
with research so given that you know all
the cards position of all the cards
there are some tree search algorithm
this kind of minimax research that can
solve it only in reality we don't see
all the cards so we see only two hands
and two half of the cards are hidden so
either like that or like that so we have
just partially observed information and
this introduces uncertainty and this
makes it more challenging so this exact
solvers are not so good anymore so by
the way the term double dummy it it
refers to the variation where all cards
are known so with open cards means
double dummy so the most which playing
program works like this so they are even
the best which playing of programs today
and this has not changed very much in
the last 20 years there were no big
breakthroughs so the input is such a
position where you know only part of the
cards and then for the hidden cards we
just randomly assign some cards there
and when we randomly assigned we have
the full position then we apply the
the double then we sold her we get the
outcome and then we repeat these end
times and then we choose the action
which was winning in most of the cases
so this seems a very very like a good
strategy but it has only one problem
that this double dummy solvers are
pretty slow so you can't afford to
sample more than 100 positions so we
have an idea how we can do better so
instead of these three are three search
algorithms which solve it exactly we can
put a neural network which takes the
bridge hand layout and will predict the
outcome so what we pay for it is that we
don't no longer have the exact outcome
but we have the approximate outcome so
we predict somewhere between 0 and 13
how many how many tricks the the
north-south team will win so here I will
show you how the how we represent the
problem for a neural network so the
input is this sum this hand on the on
the left and then we have to get to
feature vector of dimension 208 on the
right so in the middle is how how we do
this so we take this hand here and we
will represent it as like here so we
take each suit so here is a space here
is a heart diamond and clubs and then we
put there all of the cards from Ace King
down to deuce so next to all cards we we
have 0 if this hand doesn't have this
card and the one if it has it so we can
see that here the two of spades is there
and here at the King of Hearts King of
Diamonds and here two of clubs so
basically this is a binary vector just
showing which cards the
lair has and this represent one player
and then we have it four times here
because four players and each player has
four suits so if we we look at the
entire thing we just stack it on top of
each other and then we have a feature
vector of 208 features and we could
directly do a linear regression over it
because we have to predict a number of
tricks between 0 and 13 and this of
course we try to do that this is one of
our baselines and another baseline is in
a paper published in 2009 by Moustakas
st and manju so what we optimize is a
squared error because we do regression
and our evaluation metric that we care
about is a kind of accuracy so we
measure in how many percent of cases we
can predict exactly in how many cases
our prediction is is off by one trick
and how many percentage is off by two
tricks so our you can see our linear
regression approach is not very good so
only in about one third of the cases we
can predict exactly the outcome so the
the random baseline would be about 8%
and here we have like 30 36 so it's
still bad much better than random but
still they're not not very good and also
the the state-of-the-art neural network
at the moment is from this paper it can
predict the exact outcome let's say you
know about half the cases which is still
not not a lot so in this paper by
Moustakas can manjuu they also made some
experiments to measure the human
performance how humans can predict how
well humans can predict the outcomes so
they tried this with 24 players 10 of
them were really good players experts
and 14 are more amateur
players and these players were asked to
solve double dumby problems and they
were solving them depending on how much
they wanted to solve between 27 and 864
somebody solved so here here we have the
result so the experts of obviously are
better than amateurs and also they are
quite better than the state-of-the-art
neural network so here as a bridge
player I have to tell you that you're
the performance human performance
usually will depend on how much time you
take to solve the task so if I take one
hour to solve this double dummy task I'm
pretty sure I get it perfectly right but
I'm not sure especially the guy who saw
864 examples he didn't spend one hour
for each each of them but the main
conclusion from this slide is that the
humans are better than this neural
network and there is a difference
between so there are always two rows in
this table so the suit and empty so
these are just basically two different
versions of the rules so you can see
that the humans are much better at empty
but neural network are much better at
suit so this is kind of interesting so I
have some intuition why this happens but
it's a bit difficult to explain so in
maybe in the coffee-break we can go into
it so now we want to improve on our
linear regression solution and we also
want to improve on the state-of-the-art
neural network from the literature so we
do this very simply you just add more
layers add more hidden units so we have
got there one hidden layer of 1024
neurons and we put three more of 128 so
if we look at the neural network from
the literature it is very similar so it
has also this 208 input features and
then there are two hidden layers that
are quite small
so just by adding more more layers and
more neurons we already outperformed the
state-of-the-art neural network and also
in suit contract is is better than what
the human experts have done so still the
result is not very good like only 56
percent we can predict perfectly so we
would like to improve it further and the
way to improve it to make it deeper or
to make the more hidden more part more
hidden units so if we add more and more
layers then we get into problems with
the gradients and if we get if we
increase the number of hidden units then
we get too many parameters and we will
over fit and we have to we'll be too
slow to Train so here's an idea because
we know that convolutional neural
networks are very useful so how how
could we apply them for bridge so here
we'll show another representation of the
cards so this this book this is one hand
so this represent represents this hand
here this one so so we just put all the
cards in the back there and we put once
where that where this player has those
cards so jack of spades and seven of
spade and then queen jack eight and four
of hearts and so on so this is one and
then there are four four channels let's
say each each player has its own channel
so the dimension of this is 4 times 13
times 4 so we we have a convolution
filters of 1 times 4 times 4 so a
convolution filter like this and then it
also goes into the depth over the all 4
channels so then we just move it to the
right and move it
and when we reach the end then we start
with the next line and so on and when
when we reach the end and it then we are
done
so the maybe one weird thing about these
convolutions why why it is kind of like
this and not like a square so the
intuition behind this it is that if we
have a convolution like this one
it will show us the positions of the
high cards in for instance in the Spade
suit so who has the ACE who has king
queen and Jack and where where they are
in relation to each other
so until intuitively this makes a lot of
sense to know in the course of the game
how this influences the outcome
so our convolutional neural network
architecture is like this so we start
with this 4 times 13 times for block
like this one and then we apply some
convolutional filters like 32 of them
and we get the bigger block and then we
apply again 64 and it get bigger and
bigger and in the end we just collapse
this into one hidden hidden layer and we
have a fully connected layer at the end
so this is a quite typical convolution
or network architecture that's used also
in let's say in image classification but
by by today's standards this is pretty
small
so we just want to add more stuff to it
so one thing which we add is to put a
few more layers at the end so if we have
just one fully connected layers now we
have four and another thing we add one
more way of doing convolution here so
here we have an even longer convolution
over the whole suit so this is just a
kind of to show how many cards you have
in this suit and how in watch what
combinations there
are so on one part we take this
sequentially this convolutional layers
until here and then we take it also with
such a filter and the two outcomes will
just concatenate and we we have a
further four further layers there so in
between we have the usual suspects like
dropout and batch normalization but we
don't use any max pooling so even going
even further while I was doing this I
heard I've heard about the existence of
red ResNet and the skip connection and I
thought okay why not we can apply it
here as well so then I increased here a
bit the number of hidden units from 128
to 512 to make a big bit bigger and we
add also the skipped connection here and
then we repeated this block four times
so the idea behind doing this is that if
we do this skip connections it allows
you to have more depth so otherwise we
we get into these problems with
vanishing gradients but with skip
connections can help us there so indeed
this was our our best version so here
here we stop complicating so these are
our our best network that we train so
now let's look at the prediction
accuracy again so we have on the left
the our best network then the human
experts baseline and the neural network
from the literature so we notice that we
are much better than the network from
the literature we are like almost in 70%
of the cases we make a perfect
prediction and we are almost never off
then morva by more than one trick and
the we are also better than human
experts except in this no-trump setting
where the human experts still a bit
better they have a 73% accuracy but they
are the humans also make much larger
mistakes sometimes so they they have
also errors here like eighty eighty
three percent and here ninety seven so
so to go back to our original goal what
we wanted to achieve is to to make a
solver that is very fast is approximate
but very fast so we can increase the
sample size as much as possible so now
we are let's measure how many deals the
neural networks can process so the the
this is a CNN network the one without
the skip connections it it can process
thousand deals per second on on the
laptop without GPU the the one with the
skip connection can process 750 deals
per second and the exact solver they can
only process about seven deals per
second so this means that during the
same time of thinking we can increase
the sample size by hundred times and
this is important because the time
limitation is in when playing a bridge
game is under 10 minutes so in whenever
you make a decision if you want to make
these samples then you quickly run out
of time you can only think for maybe 10
20 seconds maximum 30 seconds so on the
downside our predictions are perfect
only in 70% of the cases and in 30% of
the cases they are off by one trick so
questions that are still open is how
much does it help so ok we can increase
sample size now so what
so we could answer this question by
implementing this numeral network in an
existing bridge playing software that
takes these samples just to increase the
sample see how it works so unfortunately
this I couldn't do because the bridge
playing software is none of it is open
source and it is very hard to integrate
too but you are welcome if somebody is
excited to try this out and the other
open question is how much of a problem
is it that our solvers are now not exact
anymore so we have this 30 percent error
so by my intuition this shouldn't be a
big big problem because anyway the
solver assumes when it solves the
position that everybody will play
optimally so in in reality we know that
this is not the case only because nobody
sees all cards so of the optimal
strategies that is not known but it
would be interesting to try how this
actually effect so the code the data and
the models are available on github and
on s3 so you can check it out if you
want the code is the code examples for
all of this network that I've shown is
our inner tensorflow
and I also saved there exported the
best-performing model so just on the
off-chance that somebody wants to do
some research on bridge I will show you
how to use this pre-trained model to
make predictions so we have to import
numpy and tensorflow then we load this
data which are just numpy arrays and we
create a tensor flow sessions a session
then we import this meta graph and we
load this model and then from this graph
we have to take the standard names like
x and y
and also this keep probe this is from
the from the drop out that that we used
and then we just run the session for
like the prediction and we give it our
our test set and our our creep
probability is always one so like this
you can you can solve the double dummy
problems so what lessons have I learned
so one or a very important lesson that
for me it was not obvious when I started
with neural networks is that the size of
the neural network is very important so
if it doesn't perform well enough we
just make it a double bigger bigger it
will work however overfitting was a huge
problem so usually when I do machine
learning without neural network so there
is some overfitting we are afraid of it
but usually we put some regularization
and we are fine
but here it was like a huge problem oh
it was no problem at all to to predict
perfectly on the training set but on the
test on the validation set it was a
disaster so it was this I spent a lot of
time and with different regularization
settings and the dropout worked best and
also doubling tripling the training data
also worked very well so this this would
be my two lessons here I just try drop
out I just add ten times more training
data then it will be better another
thing which I didn't expect when I
started this project is that I feel like
I spent 90% of my time tuning hyper
parameters so I just wrote the code for
the network and then I tried with this
parameter like this like this and by the
time I find the good parameters I
already forgot how I wrote the code so
it said I totally underestimated how
much time I
would be spending with tuning so yeah
another thing I learned is that this
convolution are are very useful so I'm
not surprised they are so popular
because they can help a lot with
reducing the parameter size and you can
apply it in creative ways even in the
places where there are no images and
finally I discovered that the computing
resources are essential so if you don't
have a GPU it's not worth even bothering
with this because first I tried to just
a training this network on my laptop I
thought ok a GPU will be faster but
maybe not so much so these were training
for days and then I just took the
cheapest instance from AWS and I put it
there and in one hour it was done so
from then I could iterate a lot more so
yeah since we have still some time maybe
it's worth mentioning some thoughts for
the future so now we have we have solved
the double dummy problem like at the
beginning of the game so when all cards
are still there we can predict what will
be the outcome but as the game will
progress some cards will go away because
players will have played them and then
I'm pretty sure this network will not
work anymore when there are only five
cards left or only seven cards left so
one way to solve this would be to train
the neural networks at first trick at
second and so thirteen neural networks
like this but also I think that is a
nice application for sequential models
like RN ends because actually the game
is very signal so you just put the
players put the cards one after the
other so this I haven't tried yet but
maybe I will try it in the future so
with this being said I would like you to
thank you for your attention so if you
have any questions now or or later in
the coffee break or if some of you know
how to play bridge maybe we can can play
a bit in the break so I think thanks
thanks a lot
[Applause]
you know things for the nice
presentation I have actually two
questions first is do you remember how
big and how much better the network
perform when you were adding the
additional fully connecting layers with
the idea from ResNet the shortcut like
was it very big or was it just like 1%
you meant between this and this so yeah
so this was one was like almost 70
percent accuracy and the one before like
65 percent accuracy it was a rather
small small increase that you use right
off for so above 4 cards did you
experiment with this parameter as well
yeah so yes so I use us stride of 1 and
I use padding to have the same
dimensions after that so maybe you can
think of okay why not stride of 2 or 3
so somehow from my intuition as a bridge
player I thought okay maybe it doesn't
make sense but of course it doesn't hurt
to try
it only takes a few hours to train it
again but so that's why I didn't try it
and the filter size intuition behind
yeah so this filter size of 4 would
capture all the four high cards this
picture cards this picture cards usually
mode are the most important they have
the biggest strength so that's why I
choose form so I think it would work
with with different sizes as well and
even at the end here I added one of size
13 so to capture the whole suit okay
thank you
I think so doc I'm a similar age
question
did you try varying the layer of the the
compilation step of the input just to
try and work if having coalition at all
as opposed to any particular layer was
the important factor so you mean between
this and and this one right yeah so
you've added intuition you should use
the convolution where part of the
question is is just having any
convolution Lin get enough to make a
perform or do they need to have the one
you choose so when I wasn't using
convolution layer so I was using
basically this architecture and I
experimented there a bit with different
number of layers and bigger layers and
so on
so I struggled quite a lot to improve on
this performance so I think it's
possible if I use bigger layers but I
didn't have computational resources to
to really do it but then when I tried
convolutional layer I suddenly I could
do more go more in in depth and apply
more of them so there there were much
fewer parameters to Train so I could
make progress a lot faster there so I
was reaching immediately like sixty
percent accuracy and then I was trying
to add more and more stuff until 70
percent but here I could barely move
about 55 percent so my question is more
time so you choose a particular in your
convolutions yeah
Leigha you choose a particularly or
having particular cars next to each
other in the layer are you choose that
manually so I'm getting at is the is
having convolution at all the important
factor as opposed to your particular
layer of how you map the problem to the
convolution okay okay I see
so the your question is whether the
convolution itself or this exactly
so again so yeah I don't know how to
answer this so I think that it's the
convolution having convolution at all so
I think even we increase this a bit
there two four five and make it wider it
would still work so this was just how I
thought okay maybe this makes sense
thanks again
did you try removing one of the input
layers because it's rather redundant
because when you have the information of
three players you know the cards of the
last player no I didn't try that so all
right I thought okay the simplest if I
just put everything there so in this
paper that I was mentioning in the talk
so there the authors were were comparing
many different ways of how to represent
so maybe also this idea that you
mentioned was inside I'm not sure so in
the end they found out that this was
working best for them so I thought ok it
makes sense I will just use this this
input representation
okay thanks and regarding the
convolution filters did you filter
across players did you do convolutions
across the players cards yes yes so here
you see there are these four channels
one behind the other
so each channel represents one player so
this filter also has dimensional form so
it will you would kind of see between
players like that
how big was your training that of that
so my training dataset originally was 1
million hands so I created the training
data from scratch with this solver you
know so I just put some random hand
souls with the solver and then I have
one training example so this will run
for quite a lot of time but then I could
I created 1 million so I started doing
it and then in the middle of the project
when I saw that ok I'm running a bit of
overfitting and everything so then I
created a few more million such training
examples and that helped a lot so it was
to have more data which is very limited
but intuitively it sounds like this
empty and sweet different things have
different structures so does it make
sense to train a different architecture
on it especially maybe having a
convolution which goes across the sweets
so yes so actually there are different
networks so one network is trained just
for suit and one network is straight
trained for not run and also in in the
last layer here this one so there we
actually use a different kind of
convolution which looks like a square
four by four by four so but that we use
only or deeper in the deeper layers in
the network so yeah I should have
mentioned that also
no questions so in destroying it looks
like that all the dimensions are kind of
different
so like the separate separate like in
pictures when they are kind of combined
but here each dimension represents
having different so did you try which
has some separable convolutions somewhat
separated convolutions so in the sense
that you go on you buy one channel
things like that one by one alright just
by one channel yes so for example like
now it's like only four only anyway
without mixing players or like only play
only players without mixing channels or
like all ye there are so we got mixing
other things so I didn't try but I think
that this here it was tried so so if you
look at this one here so you know you
will notice that the hidden layer is
like not full so this is one player and
then hidden layer is here fully
connected but just for this player and
then the next one also just for this
player so the players kind of don't mix
with each other at this layer here so
this is a bit if they're the same weight
yes if not the same as a girlfriend so
yeah so the answer is I don't even try
that so intuitively I thought that it
makes sense also to see what other
player what cards other players have
because they will play this card on top
of my card so it's would be important
but yeah of course it's interesting to
try out this idea as well so I didn't
write I so here that this didn't work so
well so I thought okay let's just use
similar like in images to use this on
all channels thank you
any more questions
alright then let's take the speaker
again
[Applause]